welcome to this video playing dr. Mabuza
yeah that's a an old friend of my
teammate of mine let's see I stopped
place that would think with a chair you
get them get cured of bad habits like
playing the stone wall but some bad
habits never die okay it's just them I'm
just making a little bit of fun you so
what it's not such a bad opening at all
oh it just allows that it's surprising
black gum quite often just goes back to
e7 phantom and place it like that maybe
you can play no we didn't i was thinking
g5 might might be more interesting here
than than usual
okay let's support this a little bit
yeah I was wondering that if he if he
has this move already with c5 coming up
and c5a some a bit a bit annoying if it
happens ready okay I'm taking this it's
not ideal really not but getting the C
file opened up with c5 looks even even
worse they said that is to provoke
Bishop c6 and then go back to be three
it's not doing this doing that okay
let's put this here
yeah something 25 is nice I mean I mean
what it's always a bit better here but
it's nothing nothing to were to
substantial
now this then night f4 to d3 and then
935 that's these are them the next steps
iam
gee I don't know I always feel a bit
nonplussed in this kind of positions
look some quite quite unpromising but
black I mean yeah this is not really a
move that you want to play but maybe
it's not money on nobody else yeah so
here Knight to e5 or you know I can also
play that isn't bad ready it's really
not bad if he goes not c4 I can go home
quindi one and then play be three
possibly yeah that looks good 93 is a
good strategic move yeah so back here to
play be three next
b3 is he going to see going to mp3 or
something like that that looks weird
but b3 is he has the paternal yes sir
before as a as a as an idea okay
probably dropped probably and double
okay so let's centralized this scene I
would like to get this night c4 traded
but it's probably not going to happen
easily
now probably on b3 is always jumping to
a three quite irritating ya b3 is quite
questionable anyway probably because c3
is so much weakened the end it's not so
clear what is movies before you and I'm
probably no I'm not taking see form
maybe still be three some are hard not
to play
p 393 checking everything on 67 and then
what exactly I can take you for I can
check e for and play 95 that is
interesting yeah that's in fact really
interesting probably more than that yeah
that's that's actually very strong now
that that kills us that's III idea and
its tracks and they're both nights are
amazing pieces or the night only three
sm very so very sorry piece okay so
Queen on h5 or how to do it exactly
Queen age five in fully play 27 Quincy
one he plays beef form that doesn't
really help not at all actually so
stairway to enter with Queen age five
here this position is going Queenie
seven and from there I don't know
I have released left play it Queenie
seven night Nets six might pose a
problem actually time morning queen geez
Queen f6 Queen g7 doesn't look like a
direct win but let's push the air on I
mean that this is this night there it's
not going anywhere on and 1 C 2
so aged six are taking it let's both go
time so let's let's take it so how to
win now I wanted to play a large file
its kind of kind of silly silly idea
oops i should play I don't win this I
don't believe this slack for fat son
time I had to don't see that the timer
sir sis running out him and probably I'm
hey I'm so better but it was like a
total win and not not anymore at the end
so age six is stronger check yeah I
didn't didn't a 96 a cannot really do
anything about it or 97 is strong yeah
just not in good shape at the mode 97
again was winning and I simply didn't
didn't see it but knight c6 wins yeah
okay anyway glad to have her one that in
the first place yeah blacks position is
some is really really tough to break
down as it's always should be a little
something but it's not greatest greatest
ever I think I played it okay I mean
here after this
I really think that this is a it should
be him or close to win this position air
plus 3 at so that's a lot yeah the
engine wants to check here look at this
this is of course much much better
comparison yeah black was was quite okay
but he didn't he didn't appreciate
Bishop takes e4 correctly that's
probably the the the point here and now
the two nights are just far too strong
and then we win the game okay well
thanks for watching